[Music]
soft on crime policies grabbing the
attention of a top Democrat after a
hatchet wielding Mad Men was allowed to
walk free out of jail
shocking video shows a suspect grabbing
an ax and going on a rampage to a
Manhattan McDonald's he was arrested but
neither charge he's facing was eligible
for bail under New York's lenient
criminal justice reforms the suspect
addressing critics saying quote
everybody's talking about how I should
be in jail I did my 18 hours bro what
else do you want why do I have to be in
jail I'm not unhinged I'm not psychotic
I just did what anybody would do when
being pummeled
wow and New York Governor uh Kathy
Hopewell trying to act tough on crime by
calling out Manhattan's liberal D.A
Alvin Bragg over the matter
many players in a criminal justice
system starting with the resting
officers who determined what charge to
bring as well as a district attorney who
will decide whether or not to stay with
that course or to have an up charge from
what is recommended we're actually
asking what the thought process was and
the decisions that were just made
because
we have a question about it because they
have the discretion to charge in a
different way that would make them bail
eligible
judge Shia the governor is singing uh I
think some have wanted her to conduct
herself this way do you believe what
she's saying now is genuine
I think she's worse than Cuomo wow and I
gotta tell you what she's trying to do
is she's trying to blame the district's
attorney when the truth is look this guy
is charging criminal possession of a
weapon criminal mischief both at
misdemeanors the criminal possession of
a weapon in the fourth degree if he has
a prior conviction which the New York
Post reports he has then it's third
degree and then it makes it a violent
felony but we don't know if that's the
case but criminal mischief is charged as
a misdemeanor a misdemeanor is 250
dollars he definitely did the felony
criminal mischief which is I think
fifteen hundred dollars so the D.A
charged lower probably than he could
have but it wouldn't have made a darn
bit of difference as it relates to bail
that's her problem that's her issue if
she had any honesty she would say we
have got to change the bear laws because
of my and my parties decision to have
social justice and bail for everybody
this guy walked out and I can guarantee
you Harold they gave him his ax back all
right she is the one person who has the
power to remove him from office so and
for those people who are thinking this
is more than just criminal mischief
which is a damaging property and
possession of a hatchet this is taking a
hatchet against people it's attempted
assault it's attempted murder no I got
to agree with Bragg there I would have
upped it by a degree but there's no
assault here he didn't assault anyone
with it so the governor is looking to
blame the D.A we can blame brag on a lot
of stuff but not on this one it's all in
your bailiwit governor and stop blaming
other people Jesse should we have a law
that you should not be able to take an
ax and build it in McDonald's I think
that ought to be one of the things
that'll attend the state level maybe he
was having a Big Mac attack Harold you
don't actually know his story is full of
holes and here's how I know why
he said they wouldn't let him use the
bathroom
I'm 43 years old if I am denied a trip
to the bathroom
I have to go to another bathroom
immediately I can't hold it and mess
around and play with the tomahawk for a
long time I have to go right away that's
how I know he's not telling the truth
what actually happened was he reeked of
alcohol got denied when he made a pass
at a girl hit somebody and then he got
ganged up on
he was getting pummeled by a McFlurry of
punches he's obviously unhinged you
don't go out and you say I'm not
unhinged that means you're unhinged when
you say that
then he says
the hatchet isn't for people it's for
trees and vehicles how many trees have
you seen around New York City not a lot
and what do you mean it's for vehicles
what is he going to fix a car tire with
a hatchet so obviously it's for people
then he says these people weren't lucky
because I decided I didn't want to hit
him in the throat with a hatchet so like
he's playing God and then he says
crime's always been bad it was actually
worse a long time ago because 10 years
ago he got hit in the head on the corner
with a hammer
that probably means he's mentally ill
how did they not bump up the charge and
how does how does anybody in my mind see
a video
for a kill can
carry permit the next day because that's
what I want to do I look at this I'm
never going to McDonald's again I'm
probably going to seamless and the fact
that Joe Biden is coming to New York
City tomorrow
and the White House hasn't been asked
about a viral machete ax attack Tomahawk
whatever you want to call it how does he
not get asked about that it's amazing
how they're covering this thing up the
city looks like The Shining now and the
Democrats don't even have to pay a price
for it then you know you don't look like
a big McDonald's goer like I am but if
you were to a McDonald's person could
you see yourself going back okay it's
better to get a Diet Coke than
McDonald's 100 that's not that's
absolutely true they have the why
but you're getting a diagram
I'm over a certain age so I got to think
about those things
um I was remembering last week when the
CEO of McDonald's gave a speech in
Chicago and he said
us our Corporation is staying here this
is not just because like we will always
be here it's not unconditional and he
said employees at work at his
restaurants are being harassed and we
know that that is true in New York and
probably in many other cities across the
country as well I really feel for the
workers these are people that are trying
to make an honest living they are doing
a job that maybe that maybe it's like to
get crawl up the ladder maybe that's
their first rung on the ladder and
they're working at McDonald's that's a
great place to start my sister started
there and it was a really good
experience I think there's a lot of
people now who wouldn't want their kids
to be there because of this kind of
behavior so that's also happening at
Starbucks Starbucks is starting to close
locations because their staff is being
harassed just over here the other day my
assistant went to help Bill hemmer and
goes over there 6 30 in the morning and
a homeless guy comes in takes all the
drinks that are set up for people to
pick up because that have called in you
know on their app
and so the all the Baristas had to get
down on the floor Caroline's up and then
picked the stuff up off the floor and
who would go there who would work there
and I think that we're on a real
dangerous slippery slope here if we
don't get a handle on the crime in the
city for the actual workers who come to
work every day and try to do these
businesses
Greg I know you share that view but you
had some other views in the green room
we were sharing around around this crime
I just have to correct on the story
Steve Ducey isn't homeless he was just
very very upset uh so this guy's out
I've heard from my sources that he
actually moved in with the guy who
burned down our Christmas tree this is
but my point being is that guy is out
you could see the guy who burned down
the fox Christmas tree anytime you want
and that to me is worse than this
because arson I mean that could have
been it could have killed a ton of
people but he's out so I guess what I'm
looking like I looked at this and I go
boy am I jaded I'm so jaded because the
guy sounds like he's not as crazy as
everybody else is he's maybe carrying a
an ax because somebody else has guns
he's like you know I'm going like man
I've been in New York too long to think
that this is okay because I'm looking to
go yeah and I'm watching him get beat up
this is not appropriate behavior my
point is but we've lowered the bar for
acceptable appropriate behavior in the
city in the absence of visible law
enforcement and the amplifi
amplification nation of conflict you
know we've we've lost the ability to
kind of like negotiate and dialogue so
we have this daily evidence now of uh
Reckless insane Behavior this is just a
small piece of it and when it's the Wild
Wild West you know what people start
settling stuff on their own right they
start like they they have they have
Vigilantes homeless people beat up
homeless people it I mean it's crazy
that when the laws become irrelevant
things that lawlessness takes on a weird
uh what's the word uh it's a fancy word
patina oh yes yes yeah you get machete
attacks Subway pushers you get arson get
a guy with an ax you get these insane
brawls over cold french fries you know
that's what happens when all of a sudden
chaos becomes the order of the day
you know so there you go
yes I'm getting an ax hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else